es el cuarto tiroteo masivo en eeuu en
un mes un nuevo lamento por lo que se
podría haber evitado con una mayor
regulación en la adquisición de armas en
un país donde se regalan rifles por
navidad' esta mañana tres personas han
muerto en un tiroteo en el norte de
austin la capital del estado de texas en
el estacionamiento de un complejo
residencial cuando la policía llegó se
encontró con tres personas heridas que
finalmente fallecieron los tres eran
adultos dos mujeres hispanas y un hombre
negro
un incidente que ocurrió horas después
de que en la madrugada un hombre armado
disparara y matar a al menos cinco
personas en un bar de que no sea
winsconsin ambos tiroteos sucedieron
cuando el país sigue en duelo por la
muerte de ocho personas en otro tiroteo
el jueves cuando un joven de 19 años
abrió fuego contra los trabajadores de
la sede de la compañía fedex en
indianápolis el autor del tiroteo tenía
antecedentes y según informa el 'new
york times' el joven compró legalmente
dos rifles de asalto a pesar de que en
marzo de 2020 la policía le hubiera
decomisado su arma después de que su
madre alertar a las autoridades del
preocupante estado de salud mental de su
hijo en eeuu un país de 300 millones de
habitantes se calcula que circulan 400
millones de armas la facilidad para
adquirir y poseer armas en eeuu reposa
en la segunda enmienda de la
constitución sin embargo la actual
administración quiere impulsar un cambio
de este marco legal que data de 1791 y
restringir la compra de armamento por
parte
y esto tiene que terminar es una
vergüenza nacional el congreso tiene que
dar un paso adelante y actuar el senado
tiene que actuar nunca he dejado de
apoyar la prohibición de armas de asalto
el problema es que el lobby de las armas
tiene un gran aliado en el partido
republicano estadounidense en los
últimos cinco años ha habido una
treintena de tiroteos con cuatro o más
muertos según the violence project en
2020 cerca de 20 mil personas perdieron
la vida por la herida de una bala